military leaders in guinea are seeking
to cement their grip on power after
overthrowing the government of president
alfa conde on sunday the junta says it
will set up a transitional government
but gave no timeline the international
community has widely condemned the coup
and demanded the release of the detained
president but inside the west african
country the takeover is enjoying ample
support
a rapturous welcome for guinea's
military commanders one day after they
ceased power in a coup
some citizens hail their actions as a
move against a president who was veering
into autocracy
ministers from the ousted government
were summoned to a meeting to hear their
fate
the coup leader mamadi damboya promised
to establish a transition government but
set no timeline and made no mention of
elections
a global consultation will be opened in
order to explain the major points of the
transition
afterwards a national unity government
will be put in place to drive the
transition
dumboya is a former french legionnaire
officer who had been appointed by the
president to head an elite unit
he said he was motivated by guinea's
poverty and endemic corruption
some opposition politicians welcomed the
intervention
my message to the young generation when
you are lucky enough to be in power you
should not change the constitution
africa is awoken and the african youth
today see what is happening in other
countries we are not going to stand by
idly
words aimed at the deposed president
alfa conde seen here in a video released
by the military from an unknown location
conde is a former opposition leader and
human rights professor elected in 2010
promising to begin his nelson mandela
but after two terms in office conde
changed the constitution to allow
himself to be elected again setting off
opposition protests in which dozens were
killed
recently he introduced austerity
measures including cuts to military
spending which some observers say might
have pushed the coup leaders into action
soldiers remained on the streets on
monday searching vehicles for weapons to
prevent any counter insurgency
guinea has previously spent years under
military rule
now it has entered another period of
suspended democracy